Ursprünglich hatte das spektakuläre maßnahmen projekt mal das ziel schon. Im jahr
Menschen auf dem mars siedeln zu lassen jeder konnte sich bewerben und es gab
einen riesigen medienhype das krasse laut plan werden die astronautin
astronauten nie wieder zur erde zurückkehren sondern ihr ganzes leben auf dem mars
Verbringen doch der zeitplan wurde immer weiter nach hinten geschoben und lange war es ruhig
Um mord an doch wie ist eigentlich der aktuelle stand der mission ihr habt euch dieses thema auf whatsapp
Gewünscht wir übrigens zu wort kommt dass der vater am ende
Des videos bekommen jetzt alle wichtigen facts zum thema herzlich willkommen bei klicks um science-fiction
Wir berichten ja immer wieder über die pläne private raumfahrtunternehmen menschen auf den mars zu schicken
Denn das ganze ist einfach ein richtig krasses dauerbrennerthema und super spannend und es wird früher oder später
realität ihren mast
beispielsweise mit seiner firma spacex eine rakete namens big felken rocket oder big fucking rockend soll bereits
2024 menschen zum mars schießen bis zu
200 menschen gleichzeitig will er mit dieser rakete zum mars schicken können außerdem gibt es ja noch das maß
Direct projekt von robert zu bringen hier sollen zunächst mal nur vier leute auf dem mars geschafft werden. Um dort stationen und andere
Überlebensmöglichkeiten zu installieren heute geht es hier um die pläne
des niederländischen unternehmens baselland drop um die sind wirklich großen mehrere tausend bewerbungen waren zusammengekommen
angeblich
2015 gab es dann eine erste vorauswahl seitdem stehen 100 bewerber auf der liste von denen am ende tatsächlich 40
Astronauten aus verlauten für immer eine maß kolonisation bilden sollen die castings sind wohl nicht ohne
physische und psychische tests sind zu absolvieren
Zudem gibt es auch eine exakte kopie der macht station in der sich die kandidatinnen und kandidaten auf ihr vielleicht
Zukünftiges leben vorbereiten können der nunmehr aktualisierte plan von baslers drop sieht so aus im jahr
2031 sollen die ersten vier siedler zum mars aufbrechen und ihr könnt es euch schon denken dass one-way-ticket
bedeutet keinesfalls den start einer schönen
luxusreise mit fünf sternen denn erst einmal auf dem mars angekommen werden die siedler bestimmt keine langeweile
Haben die to do liste ist lang zunächst einmal sollen sich die astronauten um ihr zuhause kümmern und die siedlung bauen
solarmodule müssen installiert werden und
Gewächshäuser gebaut werden das essen will geerntet und zubereitet werden dazu heißt es auf der website von mars wann
Unser ziel ist es den teilnehmern zu ermöglichen einen raum von zehn metern breite und 50 metern länge zu bauen also eine
Großzügige umgebung in der man leben kann und wo man auch bäume
anpflanzen kann das wird den mars zu einem viel schöneren ort zum leben machen
Wenn diese basis erst einmal steht soll dann vor allem geforscht werden wie hat sich der mars wohl
Entwickelt gibt es dort leben die astronautin astronauten sollen selbst forschen aber außerdem auch daten sammeln die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler auf der erde auswerten können
Natürlich gibt es aber auch zeiten zum entspannen lesen man sport oder aber das internet nutzen um freunde unserer mehr
zuhause zu kontaktieren oder aber filme anfordern die dann über einen server auf den mars hochgeladen werden bestimmte websites
werden tatsächlich
Ständig auf dem mars mars web server aktualisiert
andere brauchen achtung bis zu 44 minuten wenn die siedlung immer größer wird müssen die astronauten und astronauten sich auf eine art
gesellschaftssystem einigen wie sie die hierarchien und wie können
entscheidungsprozesse fair und vernünftig ablaufen das alles klingt jetzt erst mal ziemlich
entspannt aber man sagt selbst dass solch eine reise
Keinesfalls risikolos ist es könnte nicht nur probleme und unfälle bei start und landungen geben sondern auch beim eintritt in die marsatmosphäre
dazu muss man in einer offiziellen stellungnahme
massmann wird alle möglichen vorkehrungen treffen
Um sicherzustellen dass die mission so sicher wie möglich ist wenn man unsere mission allerdings mit der ersten mond mission 1969 vergleicht wird schnell klar
Dass diese mission viel sicherer ist ja so soll die rakete mehrmals unbemannt getestet werden zudem sollen kapseln bereits vor
missions- staat den eintritt in die atmosphäre simulieren doch warum genau hat sich das projekt den mars und nicht einen anderen planeten
ausgesucht wir haben ja hier schon öfter darüber
Berichtet der mars ist aus verschiedenen gründen tatsächlich ein planet auf dem man sich leben theoretisch vorstellen kann beispielsweise
Hat er zumindest eine dünne atmosphäre die vor kosmischer strahlung schützt zum anderen sind dort die
temperaturen hinnehmbar und es gibt genug sonnenlicht das man nutzen könnte
Zudem ist der tag nacht rhythmus auf dem mars denen der erde sehr ähnlich ein tag auf diesem planeten dauert 24 stunden
39 minuten und 35 sekunden also fast so wie hier auf der erde natürlich können menschen nicht einfach
So ohne technische hilfsmittel hierhin umziehen aber um es in worten von massow anzusagen
Im vergleich zur venus ist der mars ein paradies vor kurzem hat der chef des unternehmens in einem interview
Im independent auch von anderen dauerhaften siedlung außerhalb der erde gesprochen demnach kann er sich auch
missionen zu den jupiter monde und der venus vorstellen aber zurück zum mars laut dem aktuellen fahrplan auf der maas website
Steht die nächste etappe
Im jahr 2022 an dann soll eine art demo mission zum mars starten mit dabei unter anderem eine kamera
um einen video streams zu installieren zudem soll ein
Experiment zeigen das wasser einfach aus dem mars boden gewonnen werden kann und ein experiment mit
solarpanelen soll zeigen dass ausreichend erneuerbare energie für die siedlung bereitgestellt werden kann vier jahre später also
2026 sieht der fahrplan vor einen ersten rover zum mars zu bringen soll dann den besten ort für die siedlung herausfinden
2029 sollen dann laut plan sechs fracht mission starten unter anderem mit einem zweiten rover zwei wohneinheiten
und einer versorgungseinheit nachdem dann
2030 die außenposten die ankunft der ersten kurve
Im detail vorbereitet haben soll die erste kuh 2031 dann zum mars abheben und
2032 auf dem roten riesen eintreffen die besatzung wird sicherlich bis zu
48 stunden brauchen um sich an die schwerkraft zu gewöhnen schließlich waren sie die letzten sechs bis acht monate
Im weltraum unterwegs das alles steht aber noch in den sternen
denn wie bereits gesagt wurden die deadlines bereits mehrfach weit nach hinten geschoben finanziert werden soll das ganze jahr übrigens
auch durch die rechte an einer fernsehsendung die dann das leben der leute
Auf die erde überträgt big brother auf dem mars also der deal mit einer holländischen fernsehfirma der ist allerdings geplatzt
Jetzt hofft man auf sponsoren
ja viele kritiker sind schon lange davon überzeugen dass das projekt lieber in hollywood stattfinden sollte
Unseren heutigen technologien seien noch lange nicht so weit so das argument vieler
weltraum expertinnen und experten und der plan ist tatsächlich nur bereits vorhandene
technik einzusetzen um sich kostspielige
neuentwicklungen zu sparen und ja wir haben zwar schon einige roboter zum mars gebracht oder eben auch den astra corsa city im jahr
2002 aber ein roboter ist noch lange keine kuh aus astronauten astronauten bemannten flügen gelten so recht viel strengeren sicherheitsanforderungen
sowohl der staat die mehrmonatige reise
als auch die landung müssen sicher abzuwickeln sein das alles braucht vor allem starke nerven und auch die
psychologie könnte hier eine entscheidende rolle spielen das zeigen
isolationsexperiment
Wie soll die crew zusammenhalten wenn sie ausschließlich aus leuten besteht die
Egal um welchen preis einfach ruhm und ehre kassieren wollen als erste menschen auf dem mars
In die geschichte eingehen wollen und dabei den tod immer. Im nacken sitzen haben weltraumexperten
wie ein forschungsteam vom renommierten massachusetts
institute of technology mit sehen vor allem die dünne atmosphäre
Und die sauerstoffkonzentration als ein
Deutlich einschränken faktor dazu sagt oliver de weck forscher vom mtb sagen nicht
Schwarz und weiß was wann ist undurchführbar aber unter den ausgangsvoraussetzungen die sehr zeit gegeben sind ist das alles nicht realistisch
dazu kommen noch viele weitere
Medizinische und technische probleme und so gibt es schätzung dass die chance nach drei monaten auf dem mars noch
zu leben bei weniger achtung als 20 prozent liegen ja
Wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema mars besiedlungen zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hier bei potsdam
dann erfährt
er von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von clic somit machen und mehr themen
vorschlagen oder
An abstimmungen teilnehmen und damit entscheiden was hier auf dem kanal passiert ja einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
genau vergessen hier geht es weiter und dafür auch draufklicken
1000 raketen zum mars da hat ihnen masken seinen finger ins spiel ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran